can I tell you something that happened
to me I I haven't told anybody this
never happened to me before I was
outside of a 7-Eleven in Austin I'm not
gonna say which one and there was a
gentleman that approached me this was at
three or four at night which is usually
when I go I program all night and I just
like to go and take a break
he approached me in the way that maybe
somebody who recognized me approached me
he did a double take he walked past me
and then walked back and then looked at
me and I went into the 7-Eleven I
thought that's weird uh and then I I
came out with my slushie
and and then
he approached me
and he said can I give you a [ __ ]
so I have no
I have
no really yeah so the energy he put I've
never had were you wearing a suit no
okay I was wearing like uh the
sweatpants and it was very kind of like
hiding from the world yeah yeah uh type
of thing I've never had anybody approach
me that but the energy he put the love
he had in the approach I thought you'd
be like
um
I love you on Rogan yeah
something something I love some kind of
and then he just said can I I'm
forgetting the exact wording because it
wasn't
uh the the wording was such that he
wasn't he wanted to make me happy ah he
didn't want to make himself happy you
want to make me happy I forgot can I
give you a [ __ ] I think that was the
thing it's like because if you said can
you give me a [ __ ] it would be it
would be very different yeah yeah no but
I think there's more aggressive way of
phrasing that but he he presented
himself see I forget it was almost like
gentle and poetic and I was like
I I just stuttered and said no no thank
you
move past that's what everyone does yeah
no thank you
no no no no no no no thank you in my
mind I was like is this a threat
because it's fortnite uh I wasn't
exactly sure I mean I've never
experienced this I imagine this is what
sort of um women often experience the
kind of the danger the constant Threat
all around you but I've never this just
it was uh it was a funny little moment I
I didn't know what to do with it yeah
that happened and I
I go to that 7-Eleven often looking for
the guy
because now all right now I would say
yes no there used to be a steam room in
Beverly on Beverly Boulevard and
um my brother and I walked in there once
and I S and we walked in and was a man
sitting there
erection and his dick was so big he was
jerking it off with both hands
and we kind of walked in and he goes
what's up and he just did it and we just
sat there you know I mean because it was
not aggressive yeah yeah yeah maybe that
was the same fail you sense that it
wasn't an aggressive thing yeah it
wasn't yeah yeah it was just a kind it
was he was just minding his own business
and he threw it out but it wasn't also
it wasn't sexual either it was like it
was like it's just you know it's just
like it's like love or something yeah I
felt like he it's almost like can I give
you a hug right then why just take it I
I keep looking for it next time I see it
it's not in a gay one yeah yeah yeah